oh geez you never get used to seeing a
team's chances die do ya Kirk man why
you guys sound so corny all the time
oh yeah you betcha you are there guy
[Music]
so someone killed the Packers and all
they took was a briefcase with the title
to the division in it do you think of
anyone who would have a grudge against
Aaron Rodgers yes oh There He Is We got
a runner
are you a killer not in real life but in
my fantasies oh well who could care
about that
come out there Justin oh just makes the
Packer kneecap for dinner the time we
got to them they're already dead why a
wood chipper it's hardcore wait stop
oh sorry he's getting laid out shoes so
well
well hired eh oh give me yourself
I'm sorry sir who were you your coach
Kevin O'Connell you know one of mcbay's
little buddies oh hey coach so you're
saying we The Humble Midwestern Vikings
have been Killers the whole time I just
don't understand oh just ran over the
pads
[Music]
you like the radio there coach be
advised the bikes are on the run and
they do have weapons yeah but if I know
the Lakes they never get too far you're
right it's always just a matter of time
oh that's enough of that there